- [Narrator] This is kakigori.
It's a traditional
Japanese dessert similar
to the shaved ice desserts
that you probably know.
But of course, here, it
is so much more than that.
(happy music)
Let's start with a quick history.
The dish was originally a
summer treat meant to help
cool down the wealthy elite of
Japan during the late 1800s.
The ice was topped with
fruit syrups and teas grown
and harvested locally, and,
in some places, it still is.
This is Aya Eguchi in her shop in Otsu.
- [Narrator] And to get very thin ice,
there is, of course, a
special machine for that,
which you can find in
Tokyo at Kori Ishibashi.
This is Kumiko Ishibashi in her shop.
- [Narrator] How thin the ice is shaved?
Well, that depends on the weather.
- [Narrator] OK, so we've
got our pure non-freezer
made ice shaved by hand to
perfection based on the weather.
Next, we need toppings.
Our last stop is Chasanraku
tea house in Kyoto.
An area known for its matcha.
And this is Hiroki.
- [Narrator] From more
traditional matcha flavors
to mainstream ones like strawberry,
Hawaii blue, melon, cream.
This dish has range.
But the only thing that
matters at the end of the day
is how delicious it is.
(upbeat music)